هنا تصنع الكاس التي يحلم برفعها افضل
نجوم الكره على مر التاريخ ففي بلده صغيره
بالقرب من مدينه ميلانو الايطاليه تقوم
شركه
التي تاسست في اوائل القرن العشرين كل
اربع سنوات بصناعه نسخه طبق الاصل لمجسم
كاس العالم من النحاس الاصفر وهي نسخه
مطابقه للكاس التي يتم تسليمها للفريق
المتوج بلقب المحفل العالمي
هذه الكاس من قبل مديرنا الفني سيلفيو
غزانيجا وجدي وجونيو لوزه التصميم الاول
كان عباره عن مجسم الاثنين من حراس المرمى
يمسكان بالكره قبل ان يعتمد في النهايه
تصميم شخصين ولكن وهما يحملان الكره
الارضيه الكاس يبلغ ارتفاعها 38 سم وتزين
ترى بقليل من سته كيلو جرامات
الاصليه من الكاس تصنع من الذهب بعيار 18
قيراطا وتبقى في الفيفا ليستخدمها في
الاحتفال بالمباراه النهائيه ثم تعود مره
اخرى الى مقره ويحتفظ الفريق الفائز
بالنسخه المقلده
تقول فالنتينا ان جدها ومديره الفني هما
المسؤولان عن تصميم كاس العالم الايقوني
الذي انجز في عام
1971 وسلم للمتوج بلقب عام 74
ومع وصولي كاس نسخه عام 2022 الى مشارف
نهايه البطوله في انتظار كشف نقاب عن
البطل الذي سي يرفعها بدا العمل الفعلي
على مجسم عام 2026 الذي سيتم تسليمه
واعتماده قريبا للنسخه المقبله